tras seis meses de consultas sobre el
funcionamiento de la fuerza pública
francesa emmanuelle macrón presentó las
conclusiones de la iniciativa llamada
bug o de la seguridad mayor control
financiación y efectivos para la policía
y la gendarmería
el objetivo es pensar la policía de 2030
parís una policía que debe estar formada
equipada en función de las nuevas
amenazas que pesan sobre la sociedad el
terrorismo la violencia desenfrenada las
manifestaciones esporádicas la
internacionalización del crimen
el presidente francés anunció un aumento
de la financiación entre otras
cuestiones para respaldar las
disposiciones del plan bobo de cara a
2022 será a principios del próximo año
cuando macrón anunció también una nueva
ley de funcionamiento policial
en 2022 el ministerio de interior verá
su presupuesto ha aumentado en casi
1.500 millones de euros incluyendo 500
millones para la puesta en
funcionamiento de las primeras medidas
de jugo de la seguridad del sitio it
si es algo sin precedentes que todo el
curso
el 95% de las medidas que resultan de
burgos son para equipamiento
financiamiento condiciones laborales
entre las medidas anunciadas por el
presidente de la republica destacan
doblar la presencia policial para 2030
control parlamentario de la policía
hacer públicos los informes sobre las
actuaciones policiales simplificar los
procedimientos judiciales crear un
sistema para denunciar en línea la
iniciativa de bubo de la seguridad fue
desencadenada por la brutal agresión
policial a un productor de música negro
en su propio estudio sin razón aparente
y sin que opusiera resistencia la
mediatización del caso obligó a macrón a
aceptar las críticas sobre el racismo y
la violencia de la policía señalamientos
acentuados por la respuesta de la fuerza
pública al movimiento de los chalecos
amarillos